lo que quiero calcular en este vídeo es
el área debajo de la curva igual a 1
entre x cuadrada desde que x es igual a
1 el límite inferior es x es igual a 1 y
permitiendo que x crezca indefinidamente
es decir cuando x tiende a infinito así
que lo que quiero calcular es el valor
total de esta área y para calcular esto
vamos a establecer una integral impropia
una integral impropia cuyo límite
inferior es 1 y como x crece
indefinidamente su límite superior es
infinito la integral de uno infinito de
la función uno entre x cuadrada de x
hagamos patente esto esta de aquí es una
integral integral impropia un integral
impropia y como la calculamos bueno por
definición esto es igual al límite al
límite cuando n tiene infinito del
integral de uno hasta n
de 1 / x cuadrada de x lo cual está
perfecto ya sabemos cómo evaluar esto es
una integral definida con el límite
superior o igual a n y sabemos también
calcular límites tomamos el límite
cuando entiende infinito calculemos
entonces esto de aquí vamos a aplicar el
segundo teorema fundamental del cálculo
es decir tenemos que calcular primero la
anti derivada de uno entre x cuadrada
bueno escribamos primero el límite
límite cuando n tiene infinito de y
ahora sí vamos a aplicar el segundo
teoría fundamental del cálculo de la
anti derivada de una entre x cuadrada la
anti derivada de x a la menos 2 es menos
x a la menos 1 entonces esto hacer el
límite cuando entiende infinito de menos
x a la menos 1 o mejor vamos a
escribirlo como menos 1 sobre x menos 1
sobre x evaluada nn y evaluada en 1 y
esto va a ser igual entonces
esto es igual al límite cuando n tiene
infinito vamos a evaluar la anti
derivada en los límites de integración
tenemos que menos 1 / x evaluado en n es
menos 1 sobre n esto menos lo que
resulte evaluar en el límite inferior
menos 1 / x evaluado en 1 es menos 1 muy
bien vamos ahora a tomar el límite esto
que tenemos aquí no hemos tomado el
límite pues esta expresión es lo mismo
que esta expresión vamos ahora a tomar
el límite esto va a ser igual al límite
cuando n tiende infinito y que tenemos
aquí
aquí tenemos menos y menos nos da más
entonces es menos 1 entre n 1 lo cual
podemos escribir como 1 - 1 entre n y
ahora sí vamos a tomar el límite el
límite cuando entiende infinito esta
expresión existe para nuestra fortuna
aquí tenemos 1 entre n cuando en es cada
vez más grande 1 entre n se hace cada
vez más chico el límite cuando n tiende
a infinito de 1 entre en es igual a cero
por lo cual el límite de toda la
expresión es igual a 1 lo cual es
realmente sorprendente tenemos esta
región que no tiene límite superior
indefinidamente hacia la derecha
mientras que hemos encontrado que el
valor del área de la región es
exactamente igual es precisamente igual
a 1 en este caso dado que el integral
impropia resultó en un número tuvo un
valor preciso lo pudimos encontrar el
límite cuando n tiende infinito decimos
que esta integral es una integral
impropia convergente integral impropia
convergente si por alguna razón esto no
estuviera acotado no pudiéramos
encontrar un valor finito de este límite
diríamos que la integral impropia es
divergente pero en este caso encontramos
algo sorprendente esta área vale
exactamente 1